There are times when you would
like to provide more information
on a notification on a wearable device.
In this example, we have a calendar
notification but it would be handy to
show some extra reminder notes
if the user swipes to the left.
Android wear supports a concept called
pages which allow you to add extra pages
of information to
a notification like shown here.
To do this, you just create
two notification objects.
Here's the first page and
this is the start of the second page.
And then here's the second part
of the second page where we
add the style to it.
And now we create a wearable extender.
We use add page to add the second
notification to it and
then we call extend to add this
all to the first notification.
Then issue the first notification page,
and there's no need to
issue the second one.
The notification will then show
up with the second page attached.
And note, that any extra pages added
will never appear on the phone.